nos piden encontrar el valor de x en el
siguiente triángulo isósceles x es la
base de este triángulo pausa en el vídeo
y traten de encontrar x bueno la clave
para resolver esto es darnos cuenta que
la altura del triángulo que está marcada
con una línea punteada forma un ángulo
recto aquí y otro ángulo recto aquí y
fíjense que estos dos triángulos tienen
ángulos iguales porque este triángulo es
un triángulo isósceles este ángulo es
igual a este porque estamos trabajando
con un triángulo isósceles este ángulo
de 90 grados es igual a este ángulo de
90 grados y entonces el tercer ángulo
tiene que ser igual este va a ser igual
a este y sabemos que estos triángulos
son congruentes porque tienen dos
ángulos iguales y un lado igual esta
altura de 12 es igual para los dos
triángulos los dos tienen un lado que
mide 13 un lado que mide 12 y este lado
va a ser igual para los dos triángulos
este es igual a x entre 2 y este es
igual a x entre 2
y ahora podemos usar esta información y
el teorema de pitágoras para calcular la
equis dejen de usar el teorema de
pitágoras en este triángulo rectángulo
que tenemos a la derecha
podemos decir que x entre 2 al cuadrado
x entre 2 es la base del triángulo es
este lado x entre 2 al cuadrado más 12
al cuadrado es igual a la hipotenusa al
cuadrado que es 13 al cuadrado
este es el teorema de pitágoras y ahora
podemos simplificar x cuadrada sobre 4
que es x cuadrada sobre 2 al cuadrado
más 144
es igual a 13 al cuadrado que es 169 y
ahora puedo restar 144 de los dos lados
y voy a tratar de resolverlo restamos
144 de los dos lados y cuál es el
resultado del lado izquierdo tenemos x
cuadrada sobre 4 es igual a 169 menos
144 vamos a ver 169 menos 144 es igual a
25 podemos multiplicar los dos lados por
4 para despejar la x cuadrada y
obtenemos que x cuadrada es igual a 25
por 4 que es igual a 100 ahora si vemos
esto desde un punto de vista puramente
matemático diríamos que x podría ser más
días o menos 10 pero como estamos
calculando una distancia sabemos que
queremos usar el valor positivo de x así
que x es igual a la raíz cuadrada de 100
lo cual es igual a 10 positivo y lo
hicimos calculamos el valor de x la
distancia que tenemos aquí
toda esta distancia es igual a 10
la mitad de esto es igual a 5 esta
distancia que tenemos aquí es igual a 5
y sin duda alguna 5 al cuadrado más 12
al cuadrado que es 25 144 es igual a 169
que es 13 al cuadrado así que la clave
aquí es el triángulo isósceles que tiene
esta altura que divide al triángulo en
dos triángulos rectángulos congruentes y
que divide la base en dos está x entre 2
y está x entre 2 y usamos esta
información y el teorema de pitágoras
para calcular el valor de x